[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes établis hors de
france les 29 et 30 mai prochain vous
aurez à élire les conseillers des
français de l'étranger et vous délégués
consulaires par tous les républicains
bien évidemment seront présents à ces
élections c'est un moment démocratique
essentiel nous allons nous avons déjà
fait des propositions nous allons
continuer à travailler sur le fond et à
faire des propositions pour vous tous
qui êtes installés hors de france mais
qui restait très attaché nous nous le
savons bien évidemment à la france et
dans ce cadre là on peut faire
aujourd'hui la comparaison de ce qui a
été fait par notre président nicolas
sarkozy je vous rappelle que la fin du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
la scolarité des élèves de seconde
première et terminale étaient gratuites
l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron s'est
traduit par une augmentation
significative des frais de scolarité
s'est traduit par la suppression de 500
postes d'enseignants et également par
une baisse des crédits en faveur de
l'enseignement du français à l'étranger
c'est pour cela que ce moment
démocratique essentiel est qu'il faut
que effectivement nos candidats et l'est
rassemblent le maximum de voix pour que
nous puissions peser afin que à la fois
le français soit enseignée dans les
meilleures conditions à l'étranger et
surtout que les préoccupations les
soucis qui sont les vôtres au quotidien
soit bien pris en compte parce que nous
y sommes attachés
ce qui n'est vraiment pas le cas de
l'actuel gouvernement je vous invite
donc bien évidemment à voter les 29 et
30 mai mais surtout à faire voter vous
savez que l'enjeu de ces élections c'est
souvent l'absence de l'abstention et
pour cela et bien il faut compter sur
nos propres forces
communiquer faire voter vos amis vos
voisins vos collègues de travail
il faut vraiment que ce soit un grand
moment démocratique et nous vous faisons
confiance
on a besoin de vous pour faire en sorte
que nos représentants soit soit élu et
largement élu
[Musique]